as a museum we try to represent the
entire span of all life on earth and
that's what a big collection like ours
is basically therefore my name is Johan
Gerber I am the field museums
invertebrates collection manager and
today we are unboxing a deep-sea giant
isopod a deep-sea giant isopod is
basically a roly-poly like the little
things that you find in your backyard
under a board or something like that
just it's much much bigger so it's giant
and it lives in the marine realms in
depths between about 300 and 800 meters
they are scavengers so they eat mostly
dead stuff that they find fish dead
crustaceans that cephalopods Twitter and
so on even dead whales this is about as
big as this species gets about a foot
long they are not on the endangered
species list right now but we preserve
them in alcohol because that allows us
even after hundreds of years to study
their anatomy where they came from what
they are related to where they sit in
the tree of life since did this
particular specimen has not come out of
the jar for at least 20 years I would
say the preserving is done mostly by the
by the collector because you have to
preserve them right away basically you
can't put them in your suitcase and ship
them through three airports for three
days then you have a very badly
preserved specimen so they should go
into alcohol very much right away
often when I show these to the public
they are reminded of the movie alien
there is apparently a video where one of
these guys was together with a kind of
shark in a trap and in these confined
circumstances this thing could actually
latch onto the face of the shark and
started eating it so that's scary but as
I said there is really no reason to be
afraid of this it has a bit of the smell
of a dried shrimp or something like that
that you would put in a Korean soup
I suppose it's an acquired taste
you